löst sich über menschenleben genannt
wird es für mich unendlich logik macht
die beantworte ich habe schon sagen dass
fünf menschen lebe wie ein größerer
verlust sind als nur eine aber wenn man
damit verantwortet sache wird das mehr
selbstverantwortung ist mir egal ob es
fünf menschen sind oder einigte arbeiter
der einzelne das rund oval oder kenne
ich die anderen fünf arbeiter das ist so
ein moment uns auf so viel sache und ich
wird so wenig entscheiden wird so wie
ich immer entscheiden und das
entscheidet sich denn in dem moment will
alles noch nicht jemals im leben erlebt
tag sehr geehrter gläser gefühlter für
mich dann sogar entscheidung bringen